hi my name is Nick Kafka from teach a
man to fish my vision for Africa is a
continent where everyone is able to
realize their true human potential and
to make the greatest contribution they
can to their own societies and for me to
do that requires overthrowing the
colonial inherited models of education
and designing an education system that's
fit for Africa where Africans can
actually learn the things they need to
succeed in life and unlock their
potential and not just have a system
that's focused ultimately on entry into
higher education when Africans are able
to use the things they learn at school
to improve their economic situation and
to improve the capacity to take
advantage and contribute to their
community then we will have the Africa
that all Africans I think hopeful